今日は死後の世界というまあ大胆なテーマなんですけど
もしかすると副題として供養の仕方ということもありましたし
まあそのテーマ一応決められたのは
いくらか日本の仏教の世界で関心ある話題ですから
ただそれだけのことで
その問題は明確に説明できるとは限らないんです
決してそれはこういうものだよと説明することはやっぱり大変難しいし
理解したっても証拠はないし
そういう難しい問題二つあります
その上 私はすごい風邪ひいて熱が出てもう体調が最低の状態ですから
頭が混乱しているんです
だからそれ悪い原因ミス重ねているんです
まあ死後の世界といえば
簡単に言えば我々は死んだらどうなるんですかという問題なんですね
それは関心ある人も別にそんなことはどうでもいいと気にしない人も2種類がいるんですね
それからもう一つ 一つ違うところあるんです
自分の死後 いわゆる自分のおじいちゃんが亡くなってどこ行ってるんですか？とかね
おばあちゃんは亡くなったらどうなってるんですか？とか
そういう自分の家族の誰かが旦那さんであろうか
両親であろうか 亡くなったらそれも気になったりすると
そういう他人の死後はどうですかというふうにも考える方々いるんです
大体初期仏教釈迦尊のもともとの教えを説明する場として
私はまあ人の死後よりは私が死んじゃったらどうなるんでしょうかということを考えた方がもっといいんじゃないかなと思います
で まずは一応直接問題に入りますけど
我々にも死んじゃったらもう何かあるんですかね
亡くなったらまた全くそれでもう終わりですか
あるいはまた生命として我々続くんですかと
そういう 2つの問題ありまして
答えも終わるという人々もいるし
いえ 続きますよという人々もいるし
特に日本の仏教の専門の方々に聞くと
特に専門というのはお寺のお坊さんたちなんですけど
別に大学の専門家ではなくて
まあ死後の世界信じる人よりは信じない方が多いような感じもします
大学の教授たちに話したところで
そんなことはないんだと
死後の世界はないんだと
と堂々とも言うんですね
で ポイントはあるとも言えないし
ないとも言えないということなんです
明確に喋ると 亡くなったらそれから命は続きますかと
分かりませんし 続かないかということもわからないんですね
だから わからないことにいろいろいちいち説明するということは
仏教ではやらないんです
どうせわからないんだから
何でも言えるんです 例えば死後の世界あるんだと思って
いろんな妄想概念作って
おとぎ話みたいにいくらでも喋れるでしょうに
亡くなったらこうなりますよ
ああなりますよとか あるいは簡単にそんなことはないんですよ
もう人が死んじゃったら
もう細胞全部腐ってますから
それで全部終わりますよとも言えるんですね
どっちでも証拠ないんです
ですから あんまりそういう問題はそのポイントからは気にしない方がいいんです
とにかく大事なポイントは
いくら死後があってもなくても
我々はどう生きてますかと
自分の人生は一応もう何て言いますか
最終的に評価してみると
まあどういう評価できますかと
100点満点でどれぐらい自分の人生に点数入れられますかと
そのことを大事なんですね
そうすると死後があってもなくても心配することはないんです
なぜならば 我々は今ここに生きていることは確かであって
事実であって もし死後があるならば
今の生き方はまあどうでしょうね
今大失敗したんだから
来世は素晴らしい人生にしてあげませんということにはなりませんから
常識に考えると 今の人生は大失敗
もう大成功だったら この人は素晴らしく生きていましたから
来世もそれなりの生き方があるのではないかなと
いくらか常識では考えられます
で そのポイントなんです
まず考えてほしいのは
我々はどうやって生きていますかと
我々には自分の人生にどれぐらい点数を何点与えられますかと
で そこ難しいんです それもなぜかというと
人間がいろんな人生論を持ってるんです
ただ 仕事をさえバリバリやればいいんじゃないかと
男性の方が考えている方々もいるし
女性の場合はまあ子供をちゃんと育てて成長させて
もう社会人にしてあげれば
まあそれで自分の仕事終わるんじゃないかなとかね
そういうふうに思ったりする人々もいるし
で あるいは社会的に認められる人間になればいいんじゃないかなと
と思う人々もいるんですね
で そこで仏教から言いたいのは
そういうものはそんなにも
亡くなってからはあんまり計算に入りません
あまり入らないんです
すごい金儲けたんだと
抜群に そうですか 大きい巨大な会社いくつか作りましたと
会社の社長だから亡くなったら地獄に落ちるわけにいきませんだからというふうなことにはならないんですね
やっぱり仏教で言ってるのは
我々はもうよく仕事をするかしないかではなくて
もう家族の問題をちゃんと見ているかないかではなくて
もっとちょっと違うことなんですね
我々 生き方についてどういう態度を持ってますかと
この心の持ち方なんですね
で 私はよくスリランカでお子さんたちに
お母さんたちに説法するとき
こういうことを言うんですね
今 お母さんたちが子育てに追われているんだと
それでいちいち文句言いながら
まあ困りながら いろいろ混乱だらけで
もう神経質で もう必死になって子供育てる
そんな嫌々で子供子供育てると
子供にも大変ストレスかかっちゃうし
お母さんにもお父さんにもみんなにストレスかかってしまっちゃって
結局いい結果にならないんだと
で 私はどうせ子供を育てなくちゃいけないんだから
そこで自分の心の態度を変えてみましょうと
明るい心で 自分が無執着の心で
自分がまあ女性で生まれたんだから
まあそういう生物学的な原因で子供を産むようになりましたし
そこでおっぱいあげるのは男性ではなくて
どうせ女性になってる
それに男性にいくら怒ったってももうしょうがないんですね
それはどうしようもないことで
ですから そういうことで
なんで私だけ子供育てなくちゃいけないんですかと
もう子供のお父さんが何やってるんですかとかね
そういう余計なことを考えないで
ただ明るい心でせっかく生まれてきた子供を立派な人間に育て上げると
その自分の子供を客観的に見て
自分の子供を立派に育ってから
社会のためになる みんなのためになる
役に立つ立派な人として人になるように育てますとという
何かまあ宗教的というか
そういう精神的な意味を持って
そういう仕事をすると
それはもう大変素晴らしいと
そういう人々が亡くなったら必ず天国に生まれますよとお釈迦様の教訓があるんです
家の仕事をちゃんとやって
責任を果たして 旦那の仕事やら子供のことやら
家の財産のことやら 親戚のことやら
もう大変な仕事ですから
まあそういういろんなことありまして
そういうものはテキパキときちんと知恵を絞ってよくなさって
それからすごく明るくみんなの平和を保つように
喧嘩するようにではなくて
素晴らしくできれば その人はすごい精神的な修行をしているんですね
それを我々は忘れているんです
これは精神的な修行ではなくて
大変なストレス溜まっちゃうんだと
旦那さんの親戚はものすごく我が強くてうるさくて
もう嫌ですよと 会いたくもないんですよと
風に言うと やっぱり本人もかわいそうなんですね
ものすごく精神的に責められていじめられているんだから
そうじゃなくて これは修行の場だと
自分の素晴らしい精神
強い精神作るこの戦場だと思って
負けませんと 必ずこの戦い勝ち取って
自分も素晴らしい人間になって
周りにも周りの人々も幸福にしてあげると
というふうな心を入れ替えることができれば
ごく普通の日常生活の中でも
我々はいっぱい徳を積むんだと
ただ生きていること 徳を積むことになるんだと
わざわざお寺参りしなくたっても
わざわざいろんな特別な宗教的な儀式やら儀礼やら
そんなものを行わなくても
わざわざお数珠首やら手やら足やらあっちこっちかけてなくても
ただごく普通に生きている
その中 その毎日の生き方
自分の心を清らかにするために
自分の精神を素晴らしくするために
強い精神を作るために
使うならばもう死後の世界は困らなくてもいいんだと
というあのお釈迦様 このアングッリア二回アングッリ二回という大きなこのお経のテキストがありまして
それも三千以上お経入ってますけど
で そこら辺にも入ってるんです
書いてるんです で ある日
このこの帝釈天ですか
お釈迦様にあって このどうやって人々が天国に生まれますかと
聞いたところでお釈迦様の答えは
まあ男であるならば きちんと法に従って法を犯さないで
正しくお金を儲けて自分の家族を養うと
うちの奥さんも正しくこの仕来りを守って家族を守ってあげると
それからまあ窃盗したり
嘘言ったり 人のことを取ったり
まあそういう良くない行動をやめて
ごく普通に生活しているならば
どんな人でも亡くなったら天国には行くんだと
すごい簡単にお釈迦様おっしゃるんですね
その教えから見ると まあ死後の世界があると仮定するならば
まあ天国に行くということは
まあそんなに大変大胆なことではないんです
それ簡単なことなんです
ですから そこら辺にもお釈迦様の我々に言ってるメッセージがありまして
とにかく人間は立派に生きていなくちゃいけない
素晴らしい生命として生きていなくちゃいけない
いつでも誰かに文句言ったりとか
誰かに何か言ったり 誰かのせいにしたりとかね
自分の失敗をそういうふうにいつでも他人にも文句言ったりしたりする
この我々の暗い人生をいきなり入れ替えれば
明るい方向へ 誰にも文句言わない
自分の失敗は堂々と自分で認める
それで二度と失敗しないようにちゃんと気を付ける
そういうふうな生き方であるならば
もう人間として素晴らしいんだと
ふさわしいんだと だから問題は死後あるかないかではないんです
今生きてる間 我々の生き方が問います
問われますと その生き方が問題ですと
で そのところまで一応覚えておいて
で いろいろ普通の宗教の話に今から入ります
で だいたいどんな宗教にしたっても
何らかの形で死後の世界は認めているんですね
死んだら全部まるっきり終わりだと
全く終わりだと それで停止だとという宗教は世の中でないんです
で いろんな形で死後を説明するのは
まあそれぞれ宗教はバラバラなんですけど
なんとか形で死後の世界はまあ認めてはいるんです
だからといって死後の世界あるということにはならないんです
みんな言ってるんだから正しいということにならないんです
で なぜかというと この原始宗教
この文明発達する前からの宗教ありましたから
みんな死ぬのは怖かったんですね
死ということはもう大変怖いものだと思っていて
一番恐れたのは死ぬこと
死なんですね ですから
その怖いものについていろんなものを考えたりしたんです
あの エジプトの文化にしたってもね
古代文明にしたっても
やっぱり死後の世界 ある形で考えてるんですね
とにかくピラミッドなんか作った王様たちはやっぱり死にたくはないんですね
また生まれ変わりたいあるいは生き復活したいと
自分の遺体なんかはもう大事に保存してもらう
それは我々現代人はむちゃくちゃまあ放って
まあそれに邪魔して まあ王様たちに大変恨まれてるかもしれません
せっかく復活しようと思ったんだけど
その時は遺体がないんだから
ですから この一つ この単なるこの死ぬのは怖くて
もったいなくて やっぱりもったいないんだと考えて
死後の世界あると想像したというか
思った歴史もあるんですね
それだけだったら大したことないんですね
ただ 人間の希望であって
死にたくないという希望が
死んでも生まれ変わりますよという
ある願望で 希望で置き換えているだけのことなんですね
で その部分が我々はなんとことないと置いておきましょう
でも インドの世界になると
ちょっと問題は変わるんですね
インドでは心を集中して
この自己関係超えていろんなものを認識できる能力ついている人々が大勢いたんですね
いわゆる我々には認識できますけど
今知っているものしか知らないんですね
目に入るのはもう周りのものしか目に入らないし
で この生きているこの社会以外のことは全くわからない
例えば 微生物はいっぱい生きてますけど
顕微鏡ぐらいでなければ我々は存在さえ知らない
ですから 昔は人が病気になるのは悪霊のたたりだと思っていたんだから
もう顕微鏡はなかったんだから
まあいきなり人は病気になって倒れたんだから
おそらくもう誰かが悪霊がついたのではないかなと思って
もう追い払いも払いをしていましたから
ですから 我々に見えるというものはもう決まってあって
知るというものも決まってあって
それ以上のことを知りません
そこで このインドの世界で
この社会で この宗教に励んだ人々がいろいろ精神的な修行をして
この認識の範囲ですか
それをものすごく広げてみたんですね
ここにいて ここでないものも見られる能力
ここにいて 他の音でも聞こえる
このその認識の次元 全部伸ばしてみたんですね
まあ現代風に言えば 超能力では超能力なんですね
まあ超越した人間の普通の能力ですけど
わざわざ修行によって
訓練によって得たものなんです
で そういう人々は初めてこの死後の世界というよりは
過去のことを喋り出したんですね
それほとんど自分のことなんですね
自分が過去生でこういうふうにました
こういうふうにましたとか
そこで過去で過去がありましたから
まあ推測によってどうせ未来もあるだろうと
で 彼らが言いましたし
で そのポイントは 単なる死ぬのは怖いんだから考え出した一つの妄想だと簡単に捨てることはできないんです
その人々は宗教家でありましたし
現代宗教みたいに この商売のために宗教に走った人々ではなかったし
ただ単にインドの世界では
人間というのは年取ってくると
財産を捨てて 家族を捨てて真理を求めて歩き回るというふうな文化でしたから
みんな別にもう何のためでもなく
弟子を作るためでもなく
有名になるためでもなく
ただ単に真理を知りたくて
真実を知りたくて 財産も家族も全部捨てて歩くんですね
あっちこっち歩いて いろんな修行法を試してみて
自分のいわゆる超越した能力をついた人もつかなかった人もいろいろいっぱいいましたし
ですから そういう人々がわざわざ嘘をついて我々を騙してやるということは
まあちょっと理屈には合わないんです
なぜならば そういう人々にはたくさん弟子がいても
ほとんどみんなお金も使わないし
物は持ってないし 仏教と他の宗教はそれほど差がなかったんです
お釈迦様の時代でも みんなほとんど物は持ってないし
どこかで誰かからもらった食べ物をちょっとだけ食べて
それで生活しているし
ほとんど服を着ていないし
服を着るにしたっても
もう木の葉っぱとか あるいは人が捨てたものを何かとか拾って
もうなんとかちょっとだけ体を隠すだけで
そういうすごいギンギラギンのものを着るとか
そういうことでもなかったし
ですから 大勢の人々が弟子入りしたっても
その人々にとっては何の経済的な得もないんです
ただ 有名になったんだからといっても何のこともなかったんですね
ですから わざわざ人を騙して
大勢の人々を自分の超能力に
を見せて あのデモンストレーションやってだまして人を取ろうということはそれほど考えられないんですね
それは現代経済優先にしている現代人の問題なんですね
なんで宗教にしたっても
まあ経済は絡んでいると
それでまあ汚れてもうインチキ的にはなってしまっちゃうんですね
ですから この当時インドの宗教っていうのは
まあインチキということはそれほど言えないんですね
いろんな宗教ありましたけど
みんな正直に真面目に喋ってたんですね
その中でいろんな宗教で死後の世界があると言っていたんです
そこでこの現代社会では
このヒンドゥ教で輪廻転生はよく教えていますと
仏教でも輪廻転生を教えているのはヒンドゥ教から借りたものだと
まあ簡単におっしゃる学説をしゃべる方々もいますけど
あれは私はもうあまり研究していないから言うものだと思っているんです
なぜかというと このヒンドゥ教の古い一番古い経典はヴェーダ聖典というんですね
ヴェーダ聖典は紀元三千四千二千という
そこら辺の間で出来上がったものなんです
三千年前とか かなり古い仏教よりはかなり古い
そのヴェーダ聖典の中では
この輪廻とかカルマとか
そんな概念なかったんです
全然 ですから この輪廻転生の教えがヒンドゥー教から入ったものだと簡単に言い切ることはできないんです
このヴェーダ聖典の時代で
宗教っていうのは もう神様を褒め称えればそれでよろしいんだと
神様というのは 人間より力あるものは何でも神様なんですね
例えば火であろうが 水であろうか
空気であろうか 雷であろうが
何でも神様なんです そういうのは拝んだり
褒め称えたりする して
自分の現世的な幸福を
いろんな恐怖感を乗り越えるために
現世的な幸福を得るために
このヴェーダを唱えたり
サクリファイスとヤグというんですね
いろいろお供えをしたりしていたんですね
それと同時に このモヘンジョダロ・ハラッパという古代文明の中からもう発掘して
もう今はわかっているところなんですけど
この精神的な修行する伝統もあったんです
それとヴェーダ聖典は違う流れなんです
そこでヴェーダの中で
この瞑想する人々をからかって馬鹿にしている文句もあるんです
なんか変なとこいるな
人がいるんだと なんか酒を飲んで酔ったような感じで
世の中のこと何もわからなくて
もうそういう人々もいるんだと
その時でも空を飛んでいくんだというふうなことも入ってますけど
ですから ヴェーダではやっぱり瞑想する人々はそれほど好んでいなかったんです
それはあくまでもこの社会人のごく普通のこの幸福のために
まあ何て言いますか そういうのを祈祷してもらったりとか
そういうふうな感じの
それほど発展してなかったんです
でも この同じ人間の中で
きつく修行する人々もまた帰っていたんです
その人は批判されていたんだけど
その人々の生き方が一般の人々はやっぱりもう評価するようになったんですね
特に今 ヒンドゥー教で拝んでいるシヴァという神様がアーリア人の神様ではなかったんです
このアーリア人がインドを戦略する前に
モヘンジョダロ時代でもそういうシヴァがいたんです
シヴァっていうのは瞑想する誰かなんですね
そういうのは発掘して見つかってますから
そこは後でも神になって
創造する神になって 破壊する神になって
いろいろ変化してしまったんだけど
それはもうかなり時間
時間 時間 長いんだから
そういうふうに変化を受けて
今ヒンドゥー教の最大の神になっていると
それもあるヒンドゥー教のある一派の信仰であって
ヒンドゥー教の全ての人々はそういうふうに信じているわけでもないんです
シヴァ信仰がある一派だけを信じていると
とにかくその肝心なシヴァ神さえ
アーリア人の いわゆるブラフマン人の宗教のものではなかったということだけ確かなんです
そこで木の下に座って瞑想すると
お釈迦様も木の下に座って瞑想して悟り開いたんだから
それもやっぱりモヘンジョダロで見つかってるんですね
ある四角いの 何と言いますか
シールみたいなものいっぱい見つかってますから
そこに木があって その下に人が瞑想している形のものとか見つかってるんですね
ですから そういうのは昔からもう
インドの世界であった考え方で
そういう人々が真剣にいろいろ修行していろんな超能力を得て
人間が死んでそこで終わるんじゃないんだとということを言っていたんですね
それは自分の経験で言ってるんです
超越した体験で言ってるんです
ですから 我々の理屈にはわからない
違う理屈ですから 私たち理屈っていうのは
目があるんだけど 壁の外は見えない
窓にガラスは貼っていると
もう窓の外は見えますけど
カーテン閉めちゃったらもう見えないというのは我々の理屈なんですね
その仙人たちの理論というのは
まあ視覚を成長すればどんなものも認識することできるんだと
いわゆる時空関係に認識は収まりませんと
時空関係をと破っちゃえば何でも知ることできるんだとということなんですね
そういう人々はいっぱいいます
仏教だけではなくて お釈迦様はこの出家してから
先生二人に会ったんですね
一人はアーララーカーラマというんですね
2番目の先生はウッデカーラマというんですね
そのアーララーカーラマという先生もウッデカーラマという先生も
もう普通の人間には理解できない
もうかなりのことを教えていたんです
だからお釈迦様もそこに弟子入りしたんです
そこですぐ早くもその人々の真意をわかったところでこう思ったみたいんですね
この先生は 自分の先生が喋っているこの内容は
何か巨大な体験でなければ喋れませんと
単なる頭だけではそんなことは喋るくはないんだと
だから何かこの先生 精神的に優れているとつかまってるものは何かあるんだと
それ私も体験しなくちゃいけないんだと思って
ひそかに瞑想して すぐその先生得ている超越した禅定体験ですか
それ自分も得たんですね
得てから先生に報告するんですね
先生が言ってるこの宗教的な体験はこういうことではないかと
言ったら先生驚いて はあ
素晴らしいんだと 私が何か知ってるならば
それはすべてあなたが知っている
あなたが何か知っているならば
そのすべて私が知っている
であるならば ここに弟子と先生ということではありませんと
あなたは私も同じですよと自分の弟子を先生と同じくらいに扱ったんですね
ですから あなたも私と同じですから
で これから弟子たちに教えてあげましょうと言ったところでお釈迦様
それはつまらないんだと
ただ何か超越した体験があるだけで
そこでいろんなことを知っているだけで
それをみんなに教えまくって何になるんですかと
さらに探し求めていきます
お釈迦様はその先生を離れていくんですね
2番目のウッデカーラマプッタという弟子の先生のところに
そこでも勉強するし それでお釈迦様が生まれた時
お釈迦様のお父さんがのお友達がいたんですね
その友達 バラモン人ではなかったんです
商人でしたし そこで彼がこの自分の友達の王様に息子が生まれたんだと思って
その息子を見ようと思って宮殿に来るでしょうに
で ヒンドゥー教でしたから
いわゆる当時のバラモン教の国でしたから
お釈迦様の生まれた時の式だやら儀式やら
命名ですか 命名の式である
それはヒンドゥーバラモン教に従ってやりましたけど
そのこの仙人がもうただ友達として来て
で 私はあなたに息子が生まれたんだから
その息子を見ようと来たんですよと言ったら
このお父さんの先生なんですね
昔いろいろ教えてもらった
ですから お父さんも大変頭を下げて礼をして
はい わかりましたと連れてきますと
言って自分の赤ちゃんでしたからね
この自分の先生にもう礼をさせようとしているんですね
別に赤ちゃんにそんなこと言ったってわかるわけじゃないんだけど
これはもう大事な先生だから礼をしてくださいと
で 礼をさせようとしている時
このアシタという仙人ですけど
彼が立ってこの赤ちゃんに礼をするんですね
すぐ手を合わせて それを見てお父さんがすごくびっくりしたんですね
自分が拝んで帰依している偉大なる仙人が
自分の息子 もうちっちゃなこの子供に
なんで頭下げて礼をするんですかと
これすごいものだと思って
やっぱり自分の息子はもう大変なものだと
その瞬間で まあいくらいたってお父さんだからね
まあもう 自分の息子を拝んだと書いてるんですね
その話を言ったのは そのアシタ仙人がすごい超能力があった人で
そこで予言するんですね
この人はやっぱり必ず煩悩をなくして完全に悟り開くんだと
人間の唯一の人間になるんだと
生命を乗り越えるんだと
でも自分が先に死ぬんだと
先に死んで ある梵天に生まれ変わっちゃうんですね
そこに生まれ変わったら
人間とは何のコンタクトも取ることはできない
不可能なんです 他の生命と何のコンタクトもできない
ものすごい高い次元なんですけど
そこに生まれ変わっちゃうんですね
そこで生まれ変わったら
せっかくここでもう悟り開いている人がいるのに
自分には会うことはできない
これは大変な損なんですね
また二度とブッダが現れるということもわからないし
そこで悲しくて泣き出した
という話がありまして
ですから そういうその古い話で
決してあのストーリーとしていろいろ出来上がって付け加えたものはあるかもしれませんだけど
結局アシタ仙人に出会ったということだけは
どんな宗派でも認めていて
どんな経典にもある あの
まあ事実だろうと学問的には考えているんです
で このアシタ仙人の妹の息子
出家したんですね 早く出家させて
自分が自分にできないんだから
娘は妹の息子のところに行って
あんた知ってますか？と
人間の中でも唯一の存在は生まれたんだと
その人は必ず悟るんだと
出家するんだと ですから
あなたはこの全部捨てて
その人のために勉強するために出家しなさいと言われたら
お釈迦様はまだまだ子供なんです
その なのにアシタ仙人の命ですか
彼は出家したんですね
それはもうちゃんと経典に入っている
事実として入っているものなんです
ですから そういうことを言ったのは
一応歴史的な事実として
一応文献学的な事実なんですけど
その中でもこの付け加えたものは全部省いたっても
いろんな超能力を持って過去世を見られる力がある
来世をいくらか見られる力がある人々がいたということは確かなんです
それでパーリ聖典の中で
この 5つに 2回 5つに分けてあって
1番目はディーガニカーヤと長部経典と呼ぶんですね
その長部経典に 1番目の経ブラッマジャーラスッタと読むんです
その長部経典の 1番目の経はブラッマジャーラスッタといって
その中にこの 62種類の宗教
哲学 お釈迦様は分析するんです
インドではいろいろ宗教あるんだと
全部 62種類に分けて分析するんです
そこで過去を超能力で見て
宗教哲学をしゃべる人と未来を考えて宗教をしゃべる人と 2つに分けてあるんです
そこで 過去を見る人の宗教哲学の方が 44種類がありますし
いろいろ宗教哲学を言ってるんですね
でお釈迦様その宗教的なこの 62種類の教えが正しいとは言ってないんだけど
間違っても言ってないんです
お釈迦様が言ってるのは
そういう行者たちがいろんな行をなさって
超能力を得て 自分の過去を観察するんだと
過去を観察してこういう風な教えを教えるんだと
で 一度もこれはインチキだと言ってないんです
それはもう確かに彼らが何千万年も自分の過去を見るんだと
この光年というのは宇宙の時間であって
一つの宇宙が出来上がって消えるぐらい
消えている間は 1光年と計算するんですね
ですから ちょっとした時間ではないんです
その人々は自分の過去を 40光年まで見るんだと
大体見られる長さがそこぐらいみたいんですね
過去は で そこまで見て
どこまで見ても 自分がどこかでなんたかの形でいたということを発見するんですね
で発見して それで哲学を喋るんですね
お釈迦様おっしゃるのは
その自分の発見したものは正しい
認めるんだけど この哲学的に言う部分だけ人間の能力で言うんだから
そこら辺よくないんだと
一つはこのどこまで過去を見ても自分がそこで生まれているんですね
自分がいるんだと そうするとその仙人がやっぱり魂は永遠だと
物質的な世界も永遠だと
変化しないんだとすぐ決める
お釈迦様はそれにちょっとケチをつけちゃうんです
別に過去にいたこと 自分が経験したことに何も言わない
それはそれであったことを見たんだからしょうがない
でもだからといって魂は永遠だ
世界は永遠だというのはちょっと言い過ぎだと
ある人が自分の過去を見たところで
もう何個にも過去を見ていると
あるところでぶつかっちゃうんですね
ぶつかってそれ以後見えない
先生壁にぶつかっちゃう
過去を見ると そうするとその人は
ああ なるほど 私はこんなに超能力を得て
こんなに明確に明晰に過去を見ているんだけど
この次元になったらこのところでぶつかっちゃうんだと
ということは いきなり世界も私の魂もそこで偶然いきなり生まれたのではないかと
一旦生まれてから生滅変化もなしに
ずっと永遠に魂は生き続けているんだと
と決めるんです そこにお釈迦様はちょっとケチをつけるんです
いわゆる過去を見たことは正しいし
どこかでぶつかったことも正しいし
でもだから偶然に魂が生まれたんだということは言えないんだと
という風な すごいややこしい批判なんです
お釈迦様の批判というのは
能力は全部認めてあげて
能力に基づいた結論だけ良くないと言うんです
で なぜかというと その人々がある生命の次元になっちゃうんですね
そのある次元になっちゃったら
認識もない 認識もないならば
そこに自分がいたということは探せないんです
見つからない あるところでぶつかっちゃう
それ以後以降にこの人はいたんだけど
その時代ではその人の認識はなかったんです
だから認識ない生命としていたんだから
そこを乗り飛び越えないんですね
そういうふうなちょっとした問題で
もう間違ってる宗教哲学を喋ってるんだと
そういうふうな もう 62種類あるんだから
その中で超能力ない宗教というのはほんの少ないんです
それからインドではこの単なる理屈で
単なるこの言葉を操って偉そうなことを喋るのはほとんどこの認めないんです
何か精神的なことを体験していないと
ですから インドの仏教だけではなくて
どんな宗教でも この輪廻やら過去や未来のことは言ってますけど
ただ単に口先で頭だけでいろんな無茶苦茶なことを考えて
現代我々みたいに喋ってるわけじゃないので
それだったら認めないんです
そんなものは誰でも喋れるんではないかと
それは一つの特別な特色なんです
でお釈迦様を他の人々は批判したんです
その人はお釈迦様のことを批判したってお釈迦様はそんなに気にしないんですね
でもある人が お釈迦様はまあよく理屈並べて並べて
タッカパリヤハタンサマノゴートゥムダンマンデーセーティヴィーマンサーヌチャリタンサヤンパティバーナンという原文でありますけど
まあもう論理に基づいて
知識的に自分のインスピレーションですか
からいろんなことを喋っているんではないかと
別にお釈迦様にはそんなに宗教的な超一流体験なんかありっこはないんだと
そういうふうに言われると
お釈迦様も勃ちます それはすぐ攻撃するんです
黙ってはいないんです
ということは インドの社会では
宗教家が単なる理屈に基づいで
ただ知識で ただその時その時のインスピレーションだけで喋るならば
そんなものはくだらないんだと
捨てるんです ですから
自分で修行して 自分で何か知恵をつかまって
どんな宗教であろうが
仏教だけではないんです
ジャイナ教でも同じなんです
みんなすごい修行して
いろいろ体験があった人々なんです
そういうことだから 簡単に輪廻っていうのはないぞと
はないんだと 現代科学ではそんなものは説明できませんだから嘘だというのは
ちょっとあんまりもバカバカらしい話なんです
現代科学では瞑想あるんですかね
ないでしょうに じゃあ現代科学では心というものを知ってますかね
ないでしょうに 科学は知ってるのは物質だけでしょ
ですから 我々今喋ったり考えたりしているこの我々よく明確に知っている心の存在さえ現代科学では認めないんです
なぜならば長さがない
測れません 重さもない
だから時空関係に収まらなければ
科学的には存在しないものなんです
あるのに存在しないんです
ですから 科学とそこら辺はちょっと噛み合わないんです
ですから どうせ現代我々持っている科学では輪廻転生はあるかないかということは言いにくいんです
ですから 科学で見ない方がいいんです
だからといって盲信で信じる必要もない
なぜかというと インドの当時の人々が
それは自分が超越した能力を体験して
自分が見たもの 感じたものを喋りましたから
その方が知識はしっかりしているんです
例えば耳で聞くものはそれほど確かじゃないんです
物質を通して聞いているんだから
たとえ私の言葉は私同じ通りに皆さんの耳に通るということはないんです
私の発音もいろいろなまりがあるんだから
それ通るとまた違う言葉で解釈されちゃうし
ですから 私の耳で聞いたと言ったっても
そんなに信頼できません
自分の目で見ましたよと言ったっても
我々の目は結構幻覚起こしちゃいますから
例えば紙 1枚の上で我々は三次元的な絵を描いているんではないか
それ描いたところで それちゃんと三次元で認識するでしょ
でも紙の上どうやって描くんですかね
あれは 描けません 描けませんだけど
目はそういう錯覚を起こす
今皆様見たこといっぱいあるでしょうね
ステレオ写真 よくたまに本屋さんにもありますね
ちょっと目をそらして
目のポイントを絞って
絞れなくて このぼかして見ると
えらい三次元で見えるんです
ものすごい綺麗に でも実際には紙の上で印刷した映像なんですね
ちょっとこの目のピントを両方に分けて見ていると
綺麗に見えること すごい綺麗に三次元で見えてしまっちゃうんですね
その幻覚は頭の中で起こすもので
実際にあるのはただ紙の上に印刷した絵なんです
ですから 目で見るものと言ったっても
そんなに信頼できない
でも心を集中して体験するものは直接体験するんですね
そこら辺はもうきちんと信頼できると
ということで ですから
私はまあ言いたいのは
もし輪廻があるかないか知りたければ
我々もちょっと頑張ってみればどうですかと
自分の過去を見ようと
もしかすると見える可能性あります
みんなに見えないんだけど
見える可能性あります
一番見える可能性あるのは思い出し思い出しやすい過去があったならば
ですから やってみるしか方法ないんです
そこでこの科学的に輪廻転生を説明できるかないかという問題がこの現代時代で現れてきて
ヨーロッパ人と組み合っていろいろ情報を集めて
本もテキストも書いているんです
いわゆるこの人間に生まれて亡くなった人が
またどこかで生まれちゃう
生まれたらその人は自分の過去を思い出すケースがあるんです
日本でも必ずあると思いますけど
その文化の中でそれを抑えちゃうんですね
あんた何言ってるんですか
その子供が言うことは全部もう抑えちゃうんです
で インド ミャンマーとかスリランカとか
そういう国々はもう簡単に輪廻というものを信じているんだから
子供をいろんな変なことを言って言うと
もう真面目に聞くんです
そういうケース スリランカでは結構あるんです
よく新聞でも出るんです
どこかで子供が生まれて
自分の過去のことを喋ってるんだと
そうすると それはちゃんと研究をしてみるんです
もうちゃんと子供が言ってることは何ですか
何ですかとちゃんと記録して
そういう事実があったかないかといろいろな資料を調べて
その人は前で生まれたというと
本当にそんな人がいたかないかとかね
調べて それから最終的に合わせてみるんです
過去の家族とこの子供
会わせる時はもう誰誰かと教えてあげない
それで子供はほとんどのケースの場合は自分の前の自分の奥さんやら兄弟やら
もうみんな年上ですけどね
もうちゃんと確認するんですね
そういうのはどれまで確認できたかと
大体90%ぐらい正しい確認したならば
それは輪廻を証明するケースとしてまあ認めるとかね
50パー五分五分で当たったら
まあそれはまあ捨てちゃう
証明できないんだと アメリカでもイエンスティーブンというこの教授がいて
その彼がサイキックで心理学の教授ですけど
本いくつか書いてるんです
全部ケーススタディスミャンマーとインドとスリランカのところなんですね
彼が言うのは なんでその国々だけ人が亡くなったらどこかで生まれるんですかと
みんながそう生まれませんだけど
それはその国だけではないんだと
どこでもそんな同じ現象が現れるはずですと
でもたとえアメリカで子供が自分
私は私のうちはこっちじゃないよと言ったら
お母さんがあんた何言ってるんですかと
こっちはあなたのうちだよと言って
その言葉をあまり気にしないんだと
この文化的な問題で 日本でも同じことなんです
大体子供は先に言うのはそういうことなんです
これ私のうちじゃないんだと
いきなり で そうするとスリランカの場合はじゃああなたのうちはどこですかと
まあ子供の言うことだから冗談で聞くんですね
別に私のうちでないと言ったっても
子供の言うことだから
そんなに真剣に考える必要はないですし
そう聞くともういろいろなことを言うんですね
いっぱいケースがあるんです
そういうことで 現代人
科学的に考える人々に証明できる範囲なんですね
その場合も決まってあって
その場合はある人が亡くなって
また人間として生まれ変われなくては研究できない
でも 人間が死んで人間に生まれ変わるということは
どこにも言ってないんで
宗教では それだったら
この地球の人口はね 全然増えることも減ることもなく
同じまんまにあるはずでしょうに
そういうことはないんです
人間が死んだら いろんなところでいろんな次元で生まれ変われちゃうんです
そこで必ずしも過去世で人間でいて
今人間にいるわけでもないんです
そこら辺は研究はできない
で 今度私はこの来ると買ってきた本があります
それはなんで買ってきましたか？というと
あまりにもへんてこりんなことを言ってるお坊さんの本で
もうもう 100歳飛んでますけど
そのお坊さんは で みんなこのお坊さんで困ったなと言ってるんです
で テーラワーダ仏教で認めないことをいっぱい堂々と言ってるんですね
そのお坊さんがもう素晴らしい学者で
有名な人でも で いろんな話をまとめて
こういう輪廻に対する一つのケースかな
まとめてある本なんですね
ちょっと開けてみただけで読んでないんだけど
そこで開けたところであったのは
このある子供がこの前お坊さんでいて
お寺の住職でいて 亡くなってどこかで生まれちゃったんですね
普通の家庭で 生まれて赤ちゃんの時からもう自分がここはもう家じゃないんだと
私はお寺にいたんだと
ああだこうだとかいろんなこと言うと
そこを探してたケースなんですね
で かなり明確に自分のことを覚えているみたいし
そこでお坊さんでしたならば
いろいろ説法でもできるでしょうと言ったところで
その時4歳か3歳かな
まあ堂々と説法してたんだと
この説法っていうのは大変難しいんです
スリランカ人の立場から見ると
説法できるというともう大変難しいんです
向こうのしきたりに沿って喋ることは
もう出家したっても 大体年 15年ぐらい勉強しておかないとできないんです
そこで子供がもう説法するんだからといって
もう衣をちゃんと着なくちゃいけないんだと
それで自分が自分でちゃんと衣を着て
その説法するとつかまる取る何かあるんです
団扇みたいなもの それも取って
ちゃんとパーリ語をちゃんと使って説法しましたとという話なんですね
そこでこのあなたどうやって亡くなったんですかとかね
で いろいろ聞いたら 全部明確にしゃべるみたいし
必ずちゃんとそれは探してみれば
そういうお寺もあって
それは全部 で でも他のケース読んだことなんで
それもお坊さんが生まれ変わったケースなんですけど
で 子供なんですけど 生まれた子供連れて行ったら
自分のお寺に前の で 自分よりすごい年上の人々にもう名前で呼んで
あんた何でこんなことやったんですかと
なんで私のベッドはそこであったのに
あっちに運んだんですか？とかみんなに叱ったんだと
それは普通おかしいんですね
子供はお坊さんに喋る時はちゃんと敬語を使って喋るんだけど
でもその子はやっぱり自分の住職でしたから
自分の弟子たちなんですね
過去生で その癖でこういう風に喋ったとか何とか
そういうのはきちんと私は冗談っぽく言うんだけど
ちゃんと研究して それなりに研究しきたりに沿って事実を集めて分析して書いてるテキストなんです
そういうふうなまれなケース見ると
人が亡くなったら たまに人間でも生まれ変わる場合がありますよとは言えるんです
結構 まあだから輪廻転生ありますよっていう結論は
スリランカの本でも書かないんです
別にそれは科学的な結論ではないんだから
一応こういう人が過去言ったことは
過去のこういう事実ではピッタリ合いました
ということなんです ですから
人間は死んじゃったらすぐ消えるということよりは
まあそんな風に消えていかないという方が強力的な考え方なんですね
で 特にインドの世界では
みんな自分の超異せた能力があった上で言ってることでもあるし
人を騙す必要もなかったしね
ですから 真剣真面目に喋ったことなんです
ですから 我々もそれは真剣に真面目に考えた方がいいんです
で このエネルギーの不滅法則というものは
ごく普通に科学では考えているんですね
その科学者が考えているエネルギーの不滅法則っていうのは
この不滅論っていうのは
この物質が消えないってことなんですね
物質的なエネルギー で
彼らがこの心の巨大なエネルギーのことは全然気にしてない
分かってない で 心も一つの巨大なエネルギーなんですね
もし心も巨大なエネルギーであるならば
やっぱり消えないんですね
消すことはできないんですね
私は死んじゃったら遺体として残っちゃうし
それは灰になったり まあどこかこの地球には残るんだよね
その物質は消すことはできないんだから
形変えても じゃあ心のエネルギーだけ消えたんですかと
そこも言いにくいんです
それでもし心というものがあると分かれば
私は別に輪廻ということは問題にならないと思いますよ
我々に心というものはありますかね
それいとも簡単にこのわかるものだと思いますよ
例えばこの手にしたっても
何キロぐらい重い かなり重いものなんです
測ってみると結構重い
でも手を上げようという意識さえ生まれれば
いとも簡単に手を上げる
足にしたっても 足が結構重い
我々の意識のエネルギーが入ったら
足は何のことなく簡単に上がるんですね
でも 機械的に足を上げてみようと思ったら
結構エネルギーは必要でしょうに
例えば私は人の足を上げてみようと思ったらかなり疲れますよ
で もう私ももう六十五キロ重いし
六十五キロぐらい重い荷物なんか運んでみようと思ったら結構疲れますね
でも平気でこの重さを運んでいくんではないんですかね
そこら辺でこの心のエネルギーなんです
それは機械的に物理学的に説明できない
そう 体が壊れるはずでしょうに
そんなにもう例えば五
六キロぐらい走るとか
ジョギングするとか 機械は五
六キロぐらい走らせてみましょう
どれぐらい機械そのものがね
もう大変であると分かりますし
私たちは生まれた時から死ぬまでどれぐらい仕事をしているんですかね
全然何のこともないんですね
そこら辺にこの心のエネルギーが働いているんですね
そこでこの病気になったら
すぐ我々薬を飲む 薬を飲んで
この必要な成分を体に外から入れてあげる
で 心だけ瞬間に変えると
そのわざわざ高いお金を払って体に入れる物質がすぐ生まれちゃうんです
いわゆる脳細胞 ある脳細胞に我々意識を刺激すると
体を治すために必要な薬やら何らかのを作ってしまっちゃうんですね
で 体は化学工場であって
脳細胞も化学工場であると最近言ってますけど
なんでそれはその化学物質作るんですかね
なんで ある人に作るんだけど
ある人の場合は作らない
それは心のあり方なんですね
あれはなんか最近書いて大変人気あった本がありましたね
なんとか何でしたっけ
脳 脳内革命 その本を書いた先生を瞑想してくださいと
瞑想してできるだけポジティブ思考
明るく明るいイメージを作って心を喜ばせてあげてくださいと
そうするとβエンドルフィンという大変必要なホルモンを脳が作ってくれるんだと
それを作ってくれると
体の病気は全部治してくれるんだと
そこに当然東洋の人だから
精神のことを認める人だから
その先生も結構そういう修行とかなさってた人でしたから
まあ科学者が何言おうと関係なく
そういうことを堂々と言ってるんですね
自分も病院運営しているんだから
だけど そこでお医者さんが言うんだから
私たちよりは皆様一般の方々信頼しますからね
そこに同じこと書いてるんですね
心は喜び 喜んでいると
すぐこの作りにくい体に必要な化学物質は作るんですね
で そういうのはまあ 私の国でもごく普通にお医者さんたちが言ってることで
この間車でラジオをつけてあって
そこでなんかちょっと 1分
2分ぐらいのお医者さんの話がありまして
そのお医者さんがこう言うんですね
で いつでも我々は怒りやら欲やらね
そういう激しい感情を作ってはいけないんだと
その体っていうのは一つの化学工場だと
ですから ちょっとでも感情変わると
それにふさわしい化学物質が体の中ですぐ生まれちゃうんだと
そういうのは毒ですから
体を破壊して病気になるんだと
ですから いつでも明るい心でいてほしいと
特に病気になりたくなければ
たまに怒っても 怒った瞬間でそれを消してほしいんだと
なぜかというと 怒りがちょっとでも続くと
体からいろんな悪い物質が体に毒になる化学物質が生まれてきて
体を壊してしまっちゃいますと
で 彼が言うのは もし怒ったらすぐ呼吸しながら 10まで数えてくださいと
その怒ったことを忘れてしまって
その原因も全部忘れてしまって
吸って吐いて 1と吸って吐いて 2と数えて落ち着いてくださいと
そうすると早くもその悪い物質が生まれなくなって
体が元に戻るんだと それを医者さんが早く我々はね
薬を使わないで健康的にいるために必要な一つの方法として言っていることなんですね
その理論は心の存在を認めなきゃ成り立たないんですね
もし物質的にどんな化学生物も化学物質作られるならば
いくらでも作られるでしょう
そうは作られません 例えば
我々の髪の毛が白くなっていく
それはもう科学的に黒くすることできますか？できません
薬いくら飲んだって 老化する
年取ってしまっちゃう
いろんな体の臓器なんかね
老化してしまっちゃう
そういうのはいくらかでもこの老化するスピードを遅くしてもらいたければ
やっぱり心からメッセージを与えなくちゃいけない
心からメッセージを与えると
その必要な物質は心の命令で作ってしまっちゃうんですね
そういうことを今言ったのは
我々のテーマとは関係ないんだけど
この心というものは明確に存在する巨大なエネルギーなんです
体よりすごい巨大なんです
じゃあ一つの例を言いましょう
我々は立っている 立っていると眠くなっちゃう
ものすごい その時立っていられますか
単なる物理学的な人間
人間には立っていられますよと言っても
それは正しくない 立っていますという意識なければ立っていられない
倒れるんです だから眠くなってくると
みんな電車なんかえらいね
隣に迷惑かけちゃいますから
別にかけたくてかけるわけないでしょうに
ただ眠くなったら体をまっすぐにすることは不可能なんです
もし科学的な この 何て言いますか
いわゆる機械学的に説明するならば
もう立たせておけば立たせておくはずなんですね
そうはないんです この前私は説明しましたけど
人間の体全く同じ この重さを量って
我々は人の体を作った時
いわゆる像を作った時
それは立たせることはできないんです
倒れちゃうんです 人間の人物像を作ったら
我々台を作るんですね
台を作って大きくしておかないと倒れちゃいます
なぜなら我々の体 こちらの方
こちらの方 すごい重いでしょうに
上が重くて 足の裏の面積も小さいし
足は小さいし弱いし それでも立っているでしょう
だから心はあるということを言うためには
ただ私たちは立っていることだけでも十分なんです
そういうことでヴィパッサナー瞑想ではよく立ってることの観察しなさいと
ほとんどの方々がなんで立ってますかと
それはわかりませんと
と言って 瞑想だったら座ってやるものではないかと思っていますけど
ヴィパッサナーでは体と心のは別々に知りたい場合は立っていることも必要なんです
心がなければ立てませんだから
そういうことで 物質的なエネルギーと同時に心というエネルギーはあるんですね
あるならば 心には心の法則によって何か流れがあるんです
そういうことを考えると
人間が死んだってもね
そこでほっとすることはできないんです
また そのエネルギーとして続けていっちゃいます
ということは言えるんです
で あの瞑想して経験ある方々はよく知っていることで
このいくらか体膨らみ縮みとか体観察してみようと真剣に努力するんだけど
ものすごく妄想が出てきて流れていくんじゃないですか
もう我慢できないこと
嫌になること 瞑想のところじゃないんです
瞑想しようとしたっても
妄想ばっかり出てくるんですね
そこで私は妄想 妄想だって言ってカットしてくださいと言うんだけど
これいくらしたってもまた生まれる
また生まれる それを観察してみてください
心っていうのは いつでも次から次へ次から次へ生まれていくもんなんです
全然止まることはない
止まろうとしたっても
それはもう全く無理なんです
止まりません 瞑想で我々は何を狙ってますかというと
あっちこっち走り回らないで
一つのものだけ見ておこうということなんです
でも それさえできない
一つのものに集中できるようになってくると
瞑想というものは大変気持ちいい
ものすごい楽な仕事になるんです
この世の中でも一番楽しい
一番幸福な仕事になるんです
その幸福がなかなか味わえないのは
我々の心がいろんなところで走り回っているからなんです
どうしても止まらないんです
止まることは不可能なんです
可能なのは何か一つにつかまっていくことなんですね
それにもすごい努力が必要なんです
そういうことだから 皆様の経験で知っていることなんですね
心というのはすごい速さで止まることなく変わっていくんだと
じゃあ ちょっとした仏教的な論理にこれから入ります
この生滅変化論 この鈴木さん
前におっしゃいましたけど
この波動とかエネルギーとかね
まあ私もよく使う言葉ですけど
別にわかって使ってるわけじゃないんだけど
別に科学を勉強してないんだけど
波とかね であの仏教ではその波やら波動やら
そんな現代っぽくへんてこりな言葉は全然使ってないんです
もっとわかりやすい 誰にでもわかりやすい
この生滅 生まれて消えて
また生まれて また消えてとか
そういうふうなものだと
そういえば誰にでも分かりますね
物事は生まれて消えていくんだと
その生まれて消えていくことに
私はこの波動とも言って
流れとも言って いろいろ言葉を使っているんです
それはどういうことかというと
このものを電気見てもある波動で流れていくんですね
その流れていることに我々は電気と言うんです
流れない場合は電気ではないんです
で 川は川だというのは
水が流れているだからなんですね
そうでないと川ではなくなっちゃうんですね
で 私たちは言っているのは
全ての現象はそういうことであると
ですから 川の水が今ある場所から出て行っちゃう
また戻らない そこで新しい水が入るんです
そこになぜ新しい水が入ったんですかというと
ここにあった水が消えたんだから
ですから 何か消えたということは
新しいものが生まれたということなんです
それは生滅論なんですね
何か滅することは何か生まれることなんです
何か消えたということは
何か生まれたということなんです
そこは今の人生を見てもよくわかる
ある心が消えると 新しい心が生まれる
例えば怒りの心が生まれたんだと
そのすごく怒っている時は
この瞬間瞬間怒りは消えて
新しい怒りが生まれて
消えて 新しい怒りが生まれていくんですね
だから怒りにも波があるんですね
ゆっくり怒って どんどんどんどんとすごく強く怒って
またどんどんどんどん怒りが収めていくと
で その場合は自分すごく喋りたい
話し合いたい 自分好きな人が出ていく
出ていけたら 怒りながらもその人とニコニコと笑って喋れますか？喋れません
もしかすると まずその人が来たら
普通の日だったらすっごいニコッと笑って
まあいらっしゃいいらっしゃいと言うかもしれませんだけど
自分がガンガン怒っている場合は
まあその反応はない それでもその人に怒ってはいけませんから
今まであった怒りは消えていく
消えていったところで
この楽しい心がどんどん生まれてきて
もう怒りが忘れちゃって
もうお互いに仲良く楽しく遊んでいくということになっちゃうんですね
ということは この一つの心消えなければ新しい心が生まれてこないんです
同時に妄想する時でも
いろんなことを同時に妄想することはできないんです
で 妄想する時も皆様追って妄想するでしょ
一つを妄想する それに関連して次のことを妄想する
それに関連している次のことを妄想するということになっちゃいますね
だから妄想妄想と確認すると
すぐ妄想の流れが止まってしまうんです
違う意識が入れちゃったんだから
そういう風なこの消滅論があります
それすごく難しいんですけど
で 一応簡単にこういうふうに覚えておきましょう
何か消えると何か生まれる
何か消えると何かが生まれると
それは物質法則と似ているんです
ろうそくが消えるということは
炎があるということで
炎が立っているということは
徐々にろうそくが消えているということなんですね
ろうそくも消えてほしくないし
でも光も欲しいというならば
ちょっとそれは無理な話で
電気の場合も同じ 電気は使いたくないんだと
でも光も欲しいんだと言ったら
それはできないです 電気は流れると我々には光が出てくる
何か消えなくちゃいけないんですね
だから消えるということは何か生まれるということであります
それはどんなエネルギーにとっても同じなんです
心にとっても同じことなんです
そういうことだから 人が死ぬということはもう大したことじゃないんです
人は結局死なないんです
いつでも死んでるんです
いつでも我々心は変化しているんだから
物質は変化しているんだから
いつでもこの体が外からいろんな物質を入っているんですね
入って体にある物質は出て行っちゃう
そこに私の体 私の体と言うんだけど
瞬間でもその体は止まっているわけじゃないんです
流れているんです 川のように
ただ 隅田川 隅田川と言うんだけど
どっちか隅田川とは言えないんですね
ただ 感覚的に隅田川あるんだと
でも実際には瞬間瞬間それは変化していく
変化していくんだから
隅田川と何川とも言えるんですね
私の体 私の体と言うんだけど
いつでもその体は変化していく
新しい体になり変わる
体も死にかけている いつでも死ぬ
死ぬと同時に新しい物質出来上がっちゃう
それは素粒子の立場から見ると
ものすごい強烈な速さで体が変化しているということは見えます
単なる細胞で考えると
まあ遅くてゆっくり変化すると思ってますけどね
でも細胞でできているのは原子でできてあって
原子は素粒子でできているんだから
素粒子っていうのはもう何のことなく平気で変化するんだ
ですから我々の体はそういう風に川のように流れているもので
これこそ体というものは掴めない
心も同じく流れていくもので
これこそ心ということはないんです
例えば今日私の体調が良くないと
それ同時に心の状態も良くない
体調がすごく良くなって元気になってくると
心の働きも元気になってくる
そういうのは誰にでもよくあることで
ちょっと足でもどこかもし痛くなってきたら
まあ同時に心の流れももう弱くなっていっちゃうし
すぐ変化する で ニコニコと笑っている人にちょっと失礼な一言葉言っただけで
いきなり爆発してね 怒っちゃうでしょ
ちょっとしたことで変化してしまっちゃう
で そういうふうに変化するのはするんだけど
もう一つ大事なポイントは消えて新しいものが生まれる
今の状態消えて新しい状態が生まれる
そういう理論に基づいて初期仏教でこの輪廻の話をしているんです
いわゆる流れですから
もう流れてしまうんだと
そこでよくわかることは
物質はここで止まるという体はこの地球で止まる
なぜかというと 体は借りたものなんです
最後の最初の細胞も両親から借りてもらったものなんですね
両親のものなんです 体のものなんです
それに我々は地球のいろんな物質を入れて入れて入れて大きくしたものだから
この体は地球のものなんですね
これは持っていけない
地球は戻してもらうんです
どう頑張っても でも心だけは地球のものでもないんです
そのエネルギーは物質的なエネルギーではないんだから
そこには他のところにも行ける可能性があるんです
もしその心のエネルギーは地球に止どまったら
そのその辺の物質をつかまって形を取っちゃう
我々の心のエネルギーは
例えば天国に行ったならば
天国にある物質をつかまって
そこでそれなりの体を作ってしまっちゃう
犬の体に入ったならば
その物質をもらって犬になってしまっちゃう
そういう風な この心だけどこかへ飛んでいって
そこら辺で飛んでいくということでもなくて
変化して消えて 新しい心が生まれる
消えて 新しい心が生まれる
死という瞬間で心が消えちゃったら
どこか新しい心が生まれる
その生まれる場所で必要な物質はそこからもらっちゃいます
ですから 体っていうのは
どんな体であろうが借りた体なんですね
それはもう返してもらわなくちゃいけない
例えば 皆様方 過去世で天国にいたならば
この天国にいた時はあった能力やら美しさやら一つもないんです
今は その体は向こうで置いてきましたから
ここでもらったものだから
こちらの形を取らなくちゃいかない
そういう風な輪廻転生なんですね
仏教であるのは その話は
この日本でよく知っている
この成仏しましたという概念とは結構違うんです
日本でよく言うこの亡くなった方々はもう成仏できましたとかね
よくご供養できて成仏できましたとか言うんだけど
一体成仏って何ですかね
全然わかってないんです
誰に ただ言うだけなんです
あれは 何の宗教教理学的な根拠は何もないんです
ただ みんなごく普通にご供養できて
お母さん成仏できましたとか
で たまに 例えばお墓が作れなく作れないんだから困った困ったとか言って
もうやっと借金でもしてお墓できたところで
やっとお母さんも成仏できましたと
そういうのは文化的な考え方だけであって
この真理としては別に意味がないんです
それは日本の文化であって
日本人としての文化的な価値観であって
それで意味がないと 私はそう思ってるんです
なぜならば 成仏という言葉を見ると
えらい大胆な言葉なんですね
よくも失礼な言葉使うと思いますよ
あれ ブッダになるということだから
お釈迦様 ６年も苦行して悟り開かなかったのに
あれほど能力あって えらい修行してえらい苦しみを得て
もう大変なプロセスを経たところで
やっと悟り開いたところでお釈迦様自分でさえ驚いたんですね
自分に悟り開いたことができたことに
それは成仏と言うんですけど
人が会社でお金をお金を騙し取って
それで自殺したところで成仏できましたと
お墓作ったんだから そんな冗談な話
まあそういうのは別に皆様その意味を考えて言ってるわけではなくて
ただ文化的な言ってることで
それと我々の文化とこの宗教の真理の世界はあまりごちゃ混ぜにしない方がいいんです
文化は文化で守ってください
それはそれなりにありがたい話で
で 宗教の世界はまた違うんだと
もっとしっかりしているんだ
そんな大雑把なものじゃないんです
ただ お線香一つ立てて
ろうそく一つ立ててあげただけで成仏できるわけじゃないんです
成仏というのは大変なことなんです
人の仏様と言ったりしてね
そういうのは結局原始時代でもあったような慰めなんですね
人は亡くなって やっぱりかわいそうしもったいないし
悔しいし もう亡くなってほしくない
いろいろ人間の感情ありますから
やっぱり仏様にした方が遺体にするよりはいいでしょうね
ですから 遺体の仏さんというし
そういうのはもう本当にすごい失礼ですよ
テーラワーダ仏教から見ればそれは罰当たりますよと言いますよ
堂々とブッダという言葉も使ったらすごい禁じるんです
外国でも仏教の言葉やらブッダの絵やらブッダという言葉とか使ったらすぐ攻撃してそれをやめさせちゃいます
例えばブッダレストランとか
日本ででもどこかやったならば
見てください 必ずスリランカは政府として攻撃するんです
やめなさいと それはもう失礼でもあるし
ある宗教をバカにすることでもあるし
大変もう罪になる言葉なんです
やっぱり尊いものは尊いものとして尊敬しなくちゃいけないんです
遺体の仏さんといったら
まあちょっとまあそれは文化で
まあ別に僕は批判してるわけではなくて
この文化の概念と宗教の概念はまあ少々考えて区別しておきましょうということだけなんです
皆様方 それをずっと言い続けたって
別に僕は気にすることではありません
で あの 次に言いたいのはこういうことなんです
この輪廻転生もある宗教の特別な教えではなくて
仏教の特別な教え ヒンドゥー教の特別な教えではなくて
世の中にある一つ一つの事実なんです
それに宗教は関係ないんです
エネルギーの不滅論だから
キリスト教であろうが
イスラム教であろうが
仏教であろうが関係ないんです
生命は誰であろうが 死んだら物体はそこで止まる
ここで止まる それは地球から借りたものだから
でも 生命としてのエネルギーは違う形をとって
そうすると消滅変化して続くんだと
で そういうふうに見てほしい
ですから アリであろうか
亡くなったらそのアリも生命だからね
そちらに単なるアリっていうのは物質の塊ではないんですね
あれはアリで死んじゃったら
アリのアリの物体はここで止まりますけど
他のアリに食べられますけど
生命としてエネルギーは違う形を取るんです
ですから すべての生命には輪廻転生があるということは仏教の話なんですね
人間だけにあるんだとか
仏教の人だけにあるんだというふうな考え方ではない
生命にあるんだと ですから
神が死んでもどこかで生まれ変わっちゃう
神様になったところで絶対に死にませんよということは
仏教で言わない そんなことはありえないんだと
それも生命だから消滅変化しなきゃ存在しないんだよ
しないんだよと ですから消滅変化しているんだと
それだったらいつかそこでそのエネルギーの流れは消えちゃうんだと
消えたら違うところでそのエネルギーの流れが続くんですと
そこで寿命という言葉を思い出したんだけど
寿命っていうのは我々取る心が取る物質によります
で 人間がこの人間の DNA の物質をとってますから
もう 100年でぜんぜいもう壊れてしまうんですね
カメとかするとどれぐらいいるかわかりませんだけど
まあ伝統的に言えばかなり長生きするみたいし
とにかくカメは長生きするみたいですね
そういうふうな DNA 構造だったら
年 200年も軽々く生きていられるし
それでも DNA 構造だからね
まあすぐ死んでしまっちゃいます
で もっと柔らかい体だったら早く死んじゃう
虫とかね 微生物とかすごい柔らかくて
もうあまり構造は複雑じゃないんだからすぐ壊れてしまう
もし我々は例えば電子だけの構造だったら
何年持ちますかね 体が
これだったらやっぱり結構持つでしょう
今我々の体は電子で出来上がってますけど
電子で何も働きはしてくれない
やっぱり DNA の構造でないと
いわゆる大きな複雑な分子でないと体の部品が出来上がらないんですね
だから鉄を食べたっても
体には関係ないんですね
カルシウムいっぱい世の中にあります
それでダメなんです やっぱりカルシウムもやっぱりアミノ酸と混ぜて
そういう通して入らないと
もし我々の体は原子だけのもの出来上がったならば
もう何万年でも 億年でも平気でいられる可能性あるんです
でも我々知ってる限りは
そういう体は我々の世界では知りません
でも この神々とかね そういう風な世界はすごい細かい物質で出来上がってるんですね
物質が細かくなるっていうことは
結構長生きできるっていうことなんです
肉はすぐ腐ってしまっちゃいますけど
鉄やらものは腐りませんでしょう
そういう風にこの原子構造やら
それ押しのそれ押しの構造になってくると
かなり気が狂うほど長生きできるんです
そういうことで 仏教ではね
神々の寿命っていうのはもう万年単位で計算するし
梵天に生まれて変わったら光年単位で
一番最初の梵天に生まれたら
最初の下のランクに生まれたら 1 光年なんです
いわゆる地球一つ 地球ではなく
宇宙一つ生まれて消えるまで梵天としているんです
ですから その人々の体の構造は
我々には想像できない違う構造なんです
寿命っていうのは そういう風にこの体の構造によるものなんです
心にはいくらでも生きていられることはできるんです
続くことは 人間の中でも 120歳いる人を見て
60歳で死ぬ人もいて
それはその人のやっぱり親からもらったこの借りた物質の強さによりますね
例えばすごくいい車買ったらもう何年も使えるし
安い軽い車買ったら 5年間で故障してもうスクラップになってしまっちゃうし
そういうものをですね
さあ 次のポイントなんですけど
どこでどういうふうに我々生まれ変わりますかということ
で 一つ皆様知っていることがある
皆様ものすごい高熱を出したりとかね
で 意識ほとんどもう不明になったとかね
ある経験あるでしょ その時は自分の心の状態どうですかね
こういう風に考えたりいる時ではなくて
もう何も考えることもできない
もう例えばすごい重病になって
もう倒れちゃったと もう何があるかもう何もわからない状態で
もう朦朧としていて すごくあるのに
ものすごい高熱を出したら
もういろんなもうめちゃくちゃいろんなことを喋ったりするんですね
その時いろんなものを見えたりするでしょうね
あの時の心の状態を考えてみてください
その時というのは自分で自己管理できない時
心の在り方なんです もしその時
皆様がくだらないことをおかしいことを考えるならば
ちょっと心配なんです
その時にいろんな朦朧としているんだから
何考えるか我々は知りません
例えばその時 人が何言ったっても
他の看病する人と別に気にしませんし
みんな知ってますから
もう自己コントロールできませんと
例えば自分に薬をあげようとお母さんが来た時は
その子供は鬼が来たんですよと怖がったならば
その時のその子供の心の状態
それなんですね 大体死ぬ時もほとんど体の調子が悪くなっていて
この体ではもう動けない
それ以上はそれで死ぬんだから
結構死ぬ時は心配なんです
今までにどんな哲学を考えたっても
どんなすごいことを考えたり
立派なことを考えたっても
病気になって倒れて いろんな機械に入れちゃって
意識がなくなった時は
我々の意識考え方はどうなるかと
そこで次は決めちゃいます
ですから 死後があると言っても
あんまり面白い話じゃないんです
かなり怖い話なんです
それで仏教でいうのは
いつでも常にいいことを考えてくださいと
慈悲の心持ちなさいと
怒りやら嫉妬やら もう毒だと思って冗談ででもそんなことはするなと
癖にするまで明るい素晴らしい考え方
生命愛する考え方 いいことをする考え方
癖になるまで訓練して
我々は根元から立派な人間になっていなきゃダメなんです
そうすると朦朧とした時も一番素晴らしいものが自分に見えちゃうんです
それでも次の生まれは心配ないんです
僕らは結構この死にかけてる人々に会いますからね
で 大体わかるんですね
人を見たらどこに行くんですかと
わかるし その時はやっぱり結構その人の意識に喋って
明るい心を持つようにしてあげるんです
死ぬ時 で こういう現代的な社会ではね
死にかけてるお坊さんがいたらそれで嫌われちゃうんですね
ああ 嫌だと だからもうそこはもう決まってるんで
どんなところに行くかと
ですから この文化的にありがたいところは
例えばテーラワーダ仏教だったら
もう人がもう亡くなってくると
おばあさん おじいさんたちのところにお坊さんが来てたどたどれるのはごく普通のことになってるんですね
それは生きている人々はもうどうせ死にますということを知ってるし
やっぱり最期の心 最後の心の状態は清らかな立派な状態にしてあげましょうと
それは亡くなる人にとってはもう精いっぱいのやってあげる報いだと
報いというんですかね
自分からやってあげること
それだけなんですね 仏教でよく言ってるのは
そういうことを親孝行するということは
親がもう亡くなってから
天国にでもいいところに生まれ変われるように計らってくださいと
別においしいご飯をあげたっても
それはもう体をここに置いとくんだからね
死ぬちょっと前に お母さん食べたがっていたんだから
これ食べさせてあげましょうと思ったって
そんなもの全くくだらない話なのに
余計な欲が生まれちゃうし
その時は また執着する可能性あるし
あ もっとこういう美味しいものを食べたいなと
でも死にかけてるんだからしょうがないんだ
そこでえらい心配するでしょ
そうするとすごい執着して餓鬼道に落ちちまっちゃうんですね
ですから やっぱり我々は元気な時
心を直してきれいにして立派な人間にならなくちゃ
もう死後は幸福にはならないんです
それを自分で確かめることをできるんで
そういうすごい病気になって
例えば食中毒になるのは悪いんだけど
例えば何か食べ過ぎてもうあたった時とか
下痢になった時とか 体がもうガタガタ倒れてもう動かない状態になってもうろくしている時は
自分の思考方向をどういうふうに行きますかと自分で観察してみてください
それ あまりにも立派な妄想やら出てこない場合は
まあやっぱり元気になってとっからも立派な心作るしか方法ないんです
皆様方 立派な体作ろうと思ってるんですね
健康の気をつけて 美しい服を着たりとかね
全然役に立たない そんなことは
立派な心を作ることは一番大事なんです
いくら綺麗な体作ったって
これはまあ年取って汚くなって醜くなってもう死んでしまっちゃいますから
で 人間の悪いところというのは
人が亡くなったらもうなんか天国から降りたような感じですごい綺麗に
その葬式の時はね 遺体なんかはもう綺麗にするんだから
アメリカの方がもっとひどい
お化粧してキチンともうなんかすごい綺麗に作るんですね
そんなもの何の意味もないんです
死んだ人にとっては何の意味もない
人間の単なる感情だけのことで
ですから 人の死はどうでもいいんだけど
私は死にますから 私はいつでも明るく
素晴らしい 上品な品格のある心を持たなくちゃいけない
それは無理な話ではない
私は自分 実際に知ってるケースから言うならば
いろんなこのおばあちゃんたち
おじいちゃんたちに聞くと
で 全然まあ仏教にも興味ない
道徳的な興味ない人がもう亡くなる時でもみんなに文句を言うんですね
で これは熱いではないかとか
もしお茶でも飲ませたら熱いではないかとか
ここでこぼれるんではないかとか
ああだこうだとか もう自分が死にかけているのに
一生懸命面倒を見ている人々に
もういろいろ文句ばっかり
で その時はいい加減しなさい
あなたは自分で立つこともできなくて
自分で飲むこともできないんだから
親切にやってあげるんだからいい加減にしなさいと言えないでしょうに
だからはいはい わかりました
ごめんなさいとか言いながら面倒見てあげるんですね
そういうふうにいつでも文句言う人のはもう決まってるんです
行くところ 文句言われるところに生まれ変わっちゃうんですね
いわゆる苦しみのところに生まれ変われちゃう
苦しみの次元に落ちる
で 他の人が見る時も 僕はある人に聞いたら
どうですかとか 別に私はこれでもう立ち上がることもないし
まあみんな心配して 別に余計な心配しなくてもいいのにとか
お医者さん呼んだりとかね
そんなもう何も要りませんし
私はもういろんないいことをしてね
もう生きてきましたから
今は大丈夫ですよと であるおじいちゃんがこの死にかけて倒れたんですね
もう歳も飛んでいたんだけど
すごい元気でしたし それは背が高くて
で 人が倒れた時からもう
病気で倒れたわけじゃなくても
歳も歳のせいで立てないんですね
そこで家に運んだら もう自分の息子だけにすごい怒って
早くお坊さん呼びなさいと言って
私がいたんだから私が呼びなさいと
そしたら私も忙しいんだから
この息子たちが おじいさんがもううるさいんだからとかね
もしお坊さんがね 暇があったら行ってくださいと
そしたらもう何でうるさいと言うんですか？もう今朝から言ってるんだと
早く行きなさい 早く行きなさいと
そんな自分が倒れているのに
もうなんでそんなに怒るんですか？と
僕はそれ聞いたら それは当たり前でしょうと
その人は私に早く会いたいんだから
それは問題ない 僕は仕事辞めて行きますよと言って
すぐ行ったんですね やっぱり死ぬ前に行かなくちゃいけないんだから
行って話したら 別に怒ってるわけじゃなくて
早くも説法でも聞いて
何かお坊さんにお布施でもして
自分の最後の行為をしておきたいんですね
いわゆる死ぬ準備をしているんですね
もうろくはしているんだけど
覚えているのは 唯一覚えているのは
自分が修行したことやら
いろんな毎月この満月お寺に行って
もう毎月２回修行するは
いろんなもうそういう大変いい生活をしていたんだから
それしか覚えてないんですね
だからみんなもう何かご飯食べなさいとか
お薬飲みなさい そんなうるさくてしょうがない
その人にとってそんなことはどうでもいいんだと
生きてる人にとっては
やっぱりそれやめさせるわけにいきませんし
薬飲まさなくちゃいけないし
何か飲み物でも飲まさなくちゃいけないんだけど
それにもうみんなに文句言ってるだけだと
やっぱり確実にそういう人々はもう素晴らしいところに生まれ変わっちゃうんですね
ですから この我々はそういういいことを思い出せるような人間にならなくちゃいけない
いわゆる生きていて良かったんではなくて
生きていたことによっていろんな素晴らしいことをできましたと
立派な人間として生きていることができましたと
というふうなこの満足感で亡くなる場合は
もういいところに行くんですね
そういう方々は結構日本にもいますけどね
まあそういう年取っているいろんな方の顔を見ると
そういう方だったら別にまあいいところに行くだろうとはもう推測できる人々もいるんです
いくら年取っても全然誰にも文句言わない
ニコニコと笑って笑って
何も悔しいとか あれはああだこうだとか何もなく
明るく明るく 誰 誰かが面倒見てくれないとか
そういうこともなくて
素晴らしい人々いるんですね
そういう人々を見ると
すごくかわいく皆さんも感じると思いますよ
すごいおじいちゃんであろうが
おばあちゃんであろうとも
かわいくてたまらない
その心から出す波動なんですね
すごい優しい波動出しているんだから
そうするともう別に供養してもらわなくても
そういう人々がいいところに行くんです
生まれ変われる場所なんですけど
人間は必ずしも人間に生まれ変わることもないし
なぜならば人間に生まれ変わることはなかなか難しいんです
なかなか難しいんです
すっごい宝くじが当たることと同じなんです
全然当たりませんだからね
で いろんな法則によってコントロールされるんです
ですから もうなかなか生まれ変われない
人間としては で 他の生まれ変わる場所はいくらでもあるんです
もうすっごいもう数えられないほどいろんな次元があるんです
そういうどこかに必ず生まれる
そういうことで で 心を清らかにして
もう戒律でも守って 人々を助けてあげてあげたりして
人間として責任を果たしている人々は
まあ天界に生まれ変わるものだと
それすごく簡単だそうですね
そんなに難しいことではないんです
で それからこの死にたい
死ぬということを言わない人々いるんですね
それを避ける  1分でも生きていきたいと頑張っちゃう
死という言葉も使わない
生きていきたくて 生きていきたくて
あんまりにも執着している人々いるんですね
今世に 自分の財産 親戚
名誉 いろんなものに執着している
死ぬ時でもみんなに文句ばっかり言ったりして
会社はどうですかとか
財産はどうですかとか
そういう話ばっかりしたりして死ぬ人々がいるんですね
だからこの世の中に執着しているんだから
じゃあこの世の中で生まれ変わりますかと
生まれ変わりません まず心が暗い
暗い心では人間に生まれ変わりません
でも この地球にはすごい執着している
そういう人々は餓鬼道というところに落ちちゃうんですね
餓鬼道といったっても一箇所ではなくて
ものすごい幅広い次元なんです
いろんな餓鬼の種類が仏教で
この経典の中でもいろんな種類が書いてるんです
中国的な苦しみを得る餓鬼とかね
まあそれほど苦しみを得られない餓鬼とか
餓鬼って飢えているという意味の言葉なんですけど
飢えている鬼という字ですかね
書き方の で やっぱり欲望なんですね
いっぱいあって飢えているような状態なんです
この供養するのはだいたいそういう人々になるんです
餓鬼道にいる人々に供養するということは
まあするんです いわゆるこの夜中
この世に対して執着は捨ててない
亡くなったんだけど 生きている人々のところで回るしていると
で 自分が死んだんだけど
まだまだ死にましたという実感もない
そこでいろいろ供養してあげると
供養してあげるとそれはわかるんですね
わかって あ こんなことするのは死んだ
死んでからでしょうとわかったら
自分で諦めがつくんです
諦めがついたら まあ自分が亡くなったと決めたら
そこら辺で自分の次の生を定着するんですね
そうでないと なんかもう中途半端な生き方になってしまっている
それはこの大乗仏教でこの中陰と言っている言葉なんですね
テーラワーダ仏教では中陰という概念はないんだけど
あの なんか自分が死んでるんですか？あるいは生きているんですか
どっちか 他のところにいる
まあなんかはっきりしていない
そういう人々なんですね
供養してあげれば 供養はどんな形であろうか
その文化のしきたりによって供養すると
その人は一応 ああ なるほど
私が死んだんだ これは私の写真を貼って
ろうそくを立てて お坊さんがおりんを鳴らして
なんか分からないお経を上げてるんだから
まあ死んだでしょうと
もう分かりますからね
自分の親戚やら子供やら
みんなもう悲しい顔をしているし
それで私はここにいるよと言ったっても
自分に連絡できないし
そこで納得いくんですね
納得いくことによって自分の次の生をはっきりすると
それぐらい事実なんですね
この成仏とか成仏とか言っているのは
で いいところに生まれ変わるためには
やっぱり徳を積んでおかなくちゃいけない
そこで供養の正しい仕方というものをまた書いてあるんです
供養の正しい仕方というのは
例えば亡くなった人の前でご飯やらうどんやらそばやらお供えしたっても
死んだ人はそんなものを食わないんです
そこはいくらこの飲み物やら缶ジュースとかね
お墓でいっぱいもう並んでるんだけど
そういうものは生きている人々の感情だけなんですね
亡くなった人にとっては何の役にも立ちません
じゃあ見張っていてください
缶ジュースでもあげて
一度開けたことがありますかと
そういうのは文化的なしきたりとして置いておいて
それは供養だと誤解する必要はない
良くないんです それは文化的なことで
やってもやらなくたってもどっちでもいいんです
で 供養っていうのは 自分が精神的な力をもらって
いわゆる徳を積んで すごいいい波動を作って
その波動の影響を与えてあげると
それは仏教で回向という言葉を使っているんですね
それはきちんと受けられます
例えば親がいて 自分の子供たちを見ると
子供たちはすごい立派なことをやっていると
親がものすごくそれで喜ぶんですね
並ならぬ感動をするんですね
自分の子供たちがすごい立派なことをしているんだと
それほど喜びが人間にないんです
例えば 人間として一番いい喜びっていうのは
自分の子供たちが世の中ですごい立派に生きていることなんですね
別に自分に何か持ってくることとかね
もうカーネーションの花一本持ってくるとかね
そんなことでも楽しいかもしれませんだけど
それよりはすごく立派に生きているならば
それほど幸福がないんです
この回向の論 そこにもあるんです
で 例えばテーラワーダの世界では
いろいろ供養する場合はお坊さんたちにお布施して
いろいろ徳を積んじゃうんですね
徳を積んで大きな大げさなお祭りなんですけど
で して その 徳を回向しますと
そういうのは効くんです
でもうちょっとストーリーなんですけど
このビンビサーラという王様がいて
そのビンビサーラ王様とお釈迦様は友達なんですね
その王様がお釈迦様にお布施したんです
食事を でお布施したところで終わって
夜寝たら 自分がこのこの餓鬼道の人々が
生命がすっごく苦しんでいるのを見たんだと
すごい怖いことなんですね
ものすごい怖い現象を見て
みんな苦しんでいる生命がいっぱい見て
怖くなって せっかくお釈迦様に素晴らしい功徳を積んだのに
お布施して なんでその夜こんなに怖いものを見たんですかと
で 朝 またお釈迦様に会ってその話をしたんですね
話したら お釈迦様が言うのは
それはあなたがあなたの遠い遠い昔の親戚ですと
彼らがすごい遠い昔からあまり徳を積まなくて
悪いことをして餓鬼道に落ちたんだと
落ちて このブッダが現れるたびに
みんな正しく供養するんだから
供養して徳を欲しくて自分ですることはできないんです
待っていたんだと でも誰もあげなかったんだと
何回もそういうことになって
今は釈尊の時代でも同じく釈尊が生まれたんだから
今度こそでも供養してもらうんではないかなと思ったんだけど
親戚がなければ別に他の人には興味ないんだから
で やっとこのビンビサーラ王様がなんとか親戚関係あったんですね
そこでその王様にその自分の訴えを訴えたんだと
ですから どうすればいいんですか？と言ったら
まあ供養しなさいと それだったらもう一回やりますと
王様がもう一回お釈迦様と比丘たちにお布施して
このお布施は私の親戚たちに供養しますということで供養してあげたんですね
この供養したいという気持ちもなければいかないんです
自動的にはいかない そこで
その夜は彼がすごい素晴らしいこの生命として夢を見たんだそうですね
すごく幸福になっていて
でもみんな裸でしたと
幸福になったんだけど
裸でしたと そこをまたお釈迦様に聞いたら
あなたは食事やらそういうものをあげたんだけど
この生活に必要なものをあげてないんだから
そのエネルギーも必要ですよと
そういうことで また 3回目にお布施して
まあ衣やらいろんなものもお布施したんでしょう
で それでその自分の親戚たちが幸福になりましたと
いわゆる天界に生まれ変わったんだと
そういう話がありまして
その話に基づいてずっと回向の伝統がテーラワーダの社会にはあるんですが
あまり合理的な話ではないかもしれませんだけど
ですから この私たちはこの何かいいことをすると
何をするかということによってもエネルギーの差が生まれるんです
例えば 病気の人を助けてあげる精神的なエネルギーと
人々が歩くところだから道路を綺麗にしてあげましょうといういい行為のエネルギーは違うんですね
それから じゃあお寺にでも行って修行でもしてみようという心のエネルギーと
病気の人を看病するエネルギーはそれぞれ違うんですね
ですから このそのその行為が違う違うエネルギーを持ってるんです
それはすごい複雑なんです
例えば 困っている人にお金をあげる
困っている人にご飯あげる
困っている人に服なんかしてあげる
あるいは困っている人に家を建ててあげるとか
そういうやっている行為によって
我々が獲得する精神的なエネルギーは変わるんです
そういうふうに人間のこの人間バラバラでしょうね
すごい立派な家に住んでる人もいて
もうなんとかアパートで生活している人もいて
うちは大きいんだけど
ボロ屋で住んでる人もいたりとかね
まあそういういろいろありますけどね
そういうのは我々過去生のカルマのいろんな差なんですね
お金に恵まれたんだけど
健康に恵まれてないとかね
健康には恵まれてるんだけど
全然お金には恵まれてないとかね
全ては揃ってるんだけど
子供はないとかね で 立派な子供はいっぱいいるんだけど
子供の教育をほくんに見てあげるぐらいは経済能力ないとかね
それ人間でのバラバラなんですね
そういうのは人間この過去生でやったことのいろいろ結果なんです
ですから いいことをすると言ったら
決まることできない 何でもいいんだからやってくださいということが私が言いたいところなんですね
いろいろ決まらないで
いろんなことをいろんないいことをやってみてくださいと
例えばお布施するならば
お坊さんたちにお布施したってもいいし
他の誰かもうお金なくて困っている人いるならば
その人にしたってもいいし
まあ両方をしてしまえばいいんです
どこかの難民を助けるためにしたってもいいし
治療に必要な何かあげたってもいいし
もういろいろ日本の料理みたいにいろんなものをした方がいいんです
その中でカルマの場合はすごくいいカルマ
いわゆる力強いカルマ
力弱いカルマいるわ 例えば人にご飯あげたならば
まあそれはもうご飯のやり取りというのは一瞬間で消えちゃうんですね
例えば人に家を作ってあげたならば
その家はずっと残っちゃうんですね
その人はその家に住んでいて
毎日よかったという幸福感が味わっちゃうんですね
そこでその家ある限り
私たちの徳がどんどんどんどん増えるんです
で 勉強したがっている
でもお金ない人にお金あげるんだと
その場合 そのお金ない人が我々からもらった奨学金もらって
それで勉強したならば
その人の人生 それで幸福になりますから
その人生きている間 我々には徳は積むんです
私たちは先に死んじゃっても
あの人生きている間はずっと徳を積むんです
そういうふうにこのカルマのいろいろ法則があります
それも理解した方が役に立ちます
その中でも 例えば人に道徳を教えてあげて納得させたならば
正しい生き方を教えてあげて
立派に生きてなさいと教えたならば
その人はそれによって立派な人間になって
死んでもいいところに生まれ変わって
それからも幸福になっちゃうし
その人の心の方向性はどうせ精神的に道徳的に行ってしまっちゃいますから
もう計り知れないほど我々に徳が返ってくるんです
その人亡くなっていいところに生まれ変われちゃうでしょ
そこでその人は幸福になっているのは
ここで遠い昔 我々はその人を戒めたんだからなんですね
それで私たちは死んで他のところに至っても
あの徳が我々につなげてくるんです
そういうふうな この道徳ですか
徳のいろんな差があるんです
それはよく理解した方がよろしいんです
で ただの見せかけのために
有名になるためにというふうにやるのは
それほど力がないんです
例えば例えば阪神大震災の時とか
例えば日本のタレントさんとか行って
あっちこっち歌ったりして演奏したりすると
みんなサーッといてお金入れたりするんですね
そういう場合はそんなに徳がないと私は勝手に思っているんです
なぜならば タレントさん見たい
会いたい 握手したいという欲望があるんだから
もうお金あげるんですね
ですから 結局自分がこの世でその結果が得たいんですね
それで終わっちゃうか
どっちかわかりませんだけど
そうじゃなくて やっぱりその人々を助けてあげなくちゃいけないと
それはもう新聞で名前載っても載らなくてもどうでもいいんだと
いいことだからしなくちゃいけないというふうな
人間を助けてあげるんだという気持ちでやると
もっとすごく徳の方がすごく強烈になるんです
あげるのは 1万円かもしれませんよ
タレントさんに 1万円あげて握手してサインしてもらったかもしれません
ただ単に 1万円を銀行に振り込んだかもしれません
でも 徳の方が違うんです
自分の希望通りに そこら辺よくよく徳が積むようにしてくださいと
仏教ではいろんな話はいっぱいテキストありまして説明してはあるんです
その中でも瞑想することは一番徳の中で一番徳の高いんです
瞑想して心が治ったら
それはもうずっともう治って治っていく過程になっちゃうんです
それは究極的な徳なんです
説法することもすごい徳なんだそうです
聞くことも同じくすごいいい徳だそうです
なぜなら 他の話聞いて面白かったと言ったっても
説法を聞いてすごい腹が立ったりするかもしれませんだけど
やっぱり結局我々の心の弱いところにも叱られて
厳しくいろんなことを言われて
我々はもう何かの形で叩き直せますから
そういう説法を聞くとき
聞くときは素晴らしく徳が積むんです
ただ お坊さんも演出家みたいにすごく美しい言葉で綺麗な言葉でみんなの機嫌を取って
みんないい気持ちにさせてあげて説法したっても
それは一つの演出であって
それで結果が終わるんですよ
ですから 人が怒っても怒らなくても
それに気にしないで 構わないで
堂々と真理をしゃべるというのはお釈迦様の立場なんです
で 悪いことは厳しく言ったら直るならば厳しく言いなさいと
優しく言ったらその人を直すならば優しく言いなさいと
[背景音楽]全然聞かなかったらもう放っておけと
その人 優しく言っても厳しく言っても
方便で言っても 工夫して言っても
聞こうとしないんだったら
まあ放っておけ 時間の無駄だから他の人助けてあげなさいと
ふうにはなってるんです
ちょっと不親切かもしれませんけど
それは不親切ではなくて
やっぱりせっかくの自分の時間はやっぱり有効に使うということになります
ですから この徳論の中で
やっぱり一番高い徳は瞑想すること
心清らかにすること で
次に法を聞くことやら法を説法すること
次に下にあるのは まあいろんなことで生命を助けてあげることなんですね
そういうふうな 我々はいろんなエネルギーを
精神的エネルギーをもらって
そのエネルギーを常に私たちの亡くなった親戚たちに
親戚に回向してほしい
それには一周忌とかね
四十五日間とか待たなくてもいいんです
それはあんまり意味がないんです
一週間というのは これ地球の考え方であって
違う次元の生命にはそんなものは全然ないんだから
ですから 常に毎日やっぱり供養しなくちゃいけない
で 人間ですから まあ一年一回とか
まあそれもそれでよろしいし
毎日やっぱり正しく言えば毎日供養しましょうと
自分の亡くなった先祖たち
先祖たちに で 毎日供養するためには
やっぱり毎日いいことをしていないとね
今日はよく一日中喧嘩したんだから供養しません
それはちょっと良くないし
で 回向すると 供養すると
生きている人間が幸福になるということも確かなんです
で 我々の先祖が供養を受けて幸福になるでしょ
そうするとありがたくてありがたくてしょうがないんですね
なぜかというと この徳を積むことは人間でない限りはよっぽど難しいんです
特に餓鬼道に落ちちゃったら全くできない
天国に行ったら全くできない
結局かわいそうなんです
こっち徳を積んで天国に生まれたらもう何もできない
そこで楽にいることだけ
そこで銀行口座を割っちゃったら
どこか他のところに生まれ変わらなくちゃいけない
カルマが切れちゃったら
人間にはもう苦しいことはあるんだけど
結構いいことできるんです
ですから 人間にもだけ
もう他の生命にもできるんだけど
人間だけ簡単にできるんですね
徳を積む 徳を積むこと
ですから それだけはやっぱり大事に考えて無駄にしてはいけないんですね
せっかくの人生っていうのは
いっぱい徳を積んだ方がいいんです
だから毎日何かいいことすることなんですね
いつでも自分の身の回りにあるんです
いいことをしたいという気持ちが生まれてくれば
気持ちさえ生まれてくれば
いつでも何かあるんです
ですから それほど難しいことでもないんです
そこでこの先祖に回向して供養してあげると
正しく回向してあげると
その人々は大変幸福になりますから
向こう側から見ればありがたくてありがたくてしょうがないんですね
ですから その自分のいい波動で我々はきちんと守ってくれるから
災難から守ってくれて
ちゃんと守ってくれる
同時に悪いことをすると
大体もうどんどん不幸になってしまっちゃうし
悪いことをして回向できますかというと
それはできないんです
例えば自分の何か嫌な人が死んじゃったと
それ自分が一杯悪いことして
あの人にもっとひどい目に遭わせてやろうと思って
自分が悪いことをして
この悪いこともカルマだから
徳もカルマだから この悪いこと
この私は泥棒しました
銀行あるいは人を殺しました
人をぶん殴ったと その罪は私の嫌な何とか人に回向しますと言っても
それはいかないんです
向こうは受けませんから
受けちゃったらもういけますよ
大体受けませんね 例えば自分の知ってる人であろうと
私はすごい病気にかかったんだから
あなたにもその病気をうつしてあげますと言っても
我々うつしてもらえますか？いくら親切
自分の親しい人であろうか
それはうつしてもらえませんね
例えば旦那さんが何かひどい病気になったと
そこで奥さんのところに行って
やっぱりお前にもうつしてあげますからと言っても
もう怒られるだけで全然うつしてはもらわない
ですから 悪いエネルギーは相手の意思がなければ入りません
でもいいことは自然に入っちゃいます
例えば旦那さんにすごいいいことがあったんだと
例えば特別にこのボーナスが倍になっちゃったんだと
いい仕事をしたんだから
そうすると すぐ奥さんも何のことなく喜んじゃうんですね
よかったんではないか
ですから いいことはすぐ他の人に与えてあげることはできます
悪いエネルギーはそんなにできません
ですから 皆様よくわかるでしょう
このいろいろブラックマジックやったりして
あの人 何て言いますか
あの 視界するとかね いろいろありますね
世の中に それはあんまり有効じゃないんです
効かない 誰か誰かが私に対して腹が立って
わら人形を持ってきて
すごい怒りで いくら釘を打っても何のこともないんで
そんなことは 全然ブラックマジックというのは全然効き目がないものなんです
それでも効くんでしょ
あれ何ですかというと
私たちはあれを受けているんです
あれ心配して あの人本当に恨んでるんだから
もうもしかするともう何かやってるでしょうと
どこかで行って いろいろどこか神社にでも行って何か言ってるでしょうと
わら人形でも使って もう今釘でも打ってるでしょうと思って
我々は怒る 心配する するとサッとその波動が来るんです
それで不調になってしまっちゃいます
心の波動は効きますから
ですから そこら辺で勝手にやってくださいと
私の前ででもいいんだからね
そういうことをやってくださいと
参加してあげますと 自分が明るくしていれば全然効かない
この我々のインド文化だから
そういうブラックマジックとかね
まあホワイトマジックというのは
それはもう伝統的にあるもので
もうかなり古い呪文とかね
結構ありますよ やり方とかね
きちんと きめ細かく丁寧に書いて
でも あの その黒魔のプロにしても
よく言うことはそんな簡単に効くものではないんだと
かえって自分に回ってくるんだと
ですから やらない方がいいと
一応教えてあげるんです
伝統だから 弟子たちがいろいろ呪文とか勉強すると
まずいい呪文とか人を助けてあげる呪文を全部勉強して身についたところで
人の性格を見て その悪い部分も教えてあげますけど
やるなと ただなくならないように伝わってあげなさいというだけで
で いうのはこのブラックマジックやって向こうにそのエネルギー
悪いエネルギーいかなかったら
かえって自分に返ってくるんですよ
ですから すごく危ないですし
全然もう気にしない方がいいんです
そういうのは 常に綺麗な明るい心でいるならば
我々には人の視界やらね
全然効かない そういうことで
悪いエネルギーも伝わるときは伝わりますけど
それは自分の責任で 例えば人が
例えばアメリカがイラクに爆弾を落とすちゃう
ああ良かったと心で拍手すると
その殺人にをみんなに参加したことになります
何にもしていないのに
人を殺したことになるんです
だからそこはみんなよくやるんでしょう
だからそこら辺を気をつけた方がいいんです
よくこのいろんな国々で戦争があったりすると
関係ない国々の人々はテレビからニュースを見たりしてね
で ある立場をとって そういう人殺しを賛成したりはするんです
それはとっても危ないことで
いかなる理由があろうとも
生命を殺すことだけは賛成してはいけないんです
賛成すると 自分が何もやっていないのに
あの殺生の罪が自分にも返ってくる
自分の興味次第に ですから
あくまでも我々はやっぱり平和のために
生命を守るために 自由のために生きていなくちゃ
我々の人生は安全ではないのです
あまりにもいい加減すぎ
勝手に物事を判断したり
怒りを持って あの国はやっぱり爆弾を落とした方がいいんだと
そう思ってはいけない
そういうことで 今日のお話はそうします
どうもありがとうございます